guess what time it is it's time to play
pop quiz
yeah okay
it's bff abby a nurse from
atlanta hi abby you've been selected hi
all right have you been studying all
show
oh my gosh i definitely won't okay
well if you can correctly answer three
questions about today's show you'll win
a thousand dollars but it's a hundred
dollars for every question answered
right abby are you ready
i'm ready okay all right first question
who gave
patti labelle a car richard pryor
you got it your worst idea all right i'm
so nervous
okay the second question is in drew's
news we talked about
a bouquet that you can buy someone as a
gift for valentine's day now it's not
made of flowers it's a bouquet made of
what
me yes yes the best part of the chicken
i'm going to go
to blair okay okay are you ready here we
go okay the final question
what kind of pasta did uh drew cook in
cookbook club
bucatini
[Applause]
that's a thousand dollars now um
i guess that's it that's it we're out of
time that's it for the day but we're
going out with a win
thank you everybody goodbye